- [Narrator] This airfield
was once a strategic base
for Russian forces in Kherson.
Now, drone footage taken
after Moscow's retreat
in early November,
shows it littered with
destroyed military equipment.
Piles of damaged,
seemingly unusable hardware
sit on roads and fields,
offering clues on Russia's strategy
for the next phase of the war.
After losing Kherson, Russia
launched missile attacks
on Kiev and other Ukrainian cities,
but along the front lines
in Southern Ukraine,
Moscow's focusing on reinforcing
its positions further east.
So here's how images
from this liberated city,
help understand Russia's military shift
ahead of the winter,
(gunfire ringing)
when extremely cold weather
complicates operations.
But first, let's look at this airfield,
which was used by Russian forces
as a base for its aviation.
These satellite images show
how Moscow housed helicopters,
trucks, and other military equipment here,
after occupying Kherson, in
the early days of the war.
The resources were meant to
support their Army's attacks,
and a push to conquer new territory.
However, they were also
exposed to Ukrainian attacks
that inflicted heavy damage on equipment,
like these helicopters that
were hit as early as March.
And in recent months,
analysts say, "Those positions
had become untenable,
as Ukraine also hit supply lines
and infrastructure like this bridge,
making it difficult for
Russia to send ammunition,
and in the long-term,
support any attacks."
Russia's Defense Minister
announced the withdrawal from
the area on November 9th,
saying, "The safety and well-being
of military personnel was paramount."
"But weeks before that announcement,
Russia had already started
to withdraw its soldiers
as it also evacuates civilians,"
that's according to analysts,
and Kherson residents who say,
"They noticed unusual
movements since October."
Troops took the time
to move equipment across
the Dnieper River,
towards territory Russia
controls in the East.
The process appeared to be more organized
than earlier Russian retreats.
In the Kharkiv Region, for example,
Russian troops were
forced down in September,
after a surprise counteract by Ukraine.
Back then, the Ukrainian Army
took over tanks, howitzers,
and many other functioning weapons.
But in Kherson, the vast
majority of the gear left behind
appeared to be heavily damaged,
pointing to what analysts say,
"Is a pre-planned operation."
Although Ukrainian propaganda videos
promoted the idea
that Russia had abandoned
valuable tanks and ammunition,
defense analysts and WSJ
reporters in Kherson said,
"The number of recovered weapons
appears to be minimal."
Weapons experts who
review these images say,
"They believe some tanks
and armored vehicles
were intentionally destroyed
by Russian forces before they fled,
so they couldn't be
used by the Ukrainians."
(crowd cheering)
For Ukraine, taking back Kherson
was an important symbolic victory.
Military analysts say,
"Moscow has paired some losses,
and has the possibility
to reorganize and redeploy
to other fronts in the East,
where it has also
struggled to make gains."
For both armies, analysts say,
"It's also a chance to
replenish their armories,
and stock up supplies
as temperatures fall,
and combat conditions
become more challenging.
(tranquil music)
(wind gushing)